this spinal cord is the body's
information superhighway constantly
buzzing with electrochemical signals
between the brain and the rest of the
body this precious bundle of nerve
fibers runs through a cavity within each
vertebra this protects the cord along
its length
but even this bony armor can't protect
the spinal cord from the worst injuries
with enough force this delicate cords
can get damaged cutting off all
communication to and from the body below
the injury site leaving a patient
paralyzed this devastating injury
happens to an estimated half a million
people each year across the globe to
make things worse the damage is
irreversible neurons of the central
nervous system
don't seem to be able to regrow their
axons the long spindly projections that
link them to other neurons scientists
are currently working to understand why
these injured nerves can't repair
themselves and regrow their axons at the
same time researchers are trying to
reboot the regeneration process so far
most of the research has been done on
rodents with researchers using three
broad approaches to try to tackle the
problem the first strategy is to change
the environment swelling around the
damaged nerves to make it more growth
friendly by dialing down chemicals that
inhibit the ability of nerves to
regenerate one set of molecules that are
suspected of blocking regeneration are
called chondroitin sulfate proteoglycans
cspgs scientists have shown that by
using an enzyme called chondroitin aides
they can change the structure of the SI
SPG molecules so that they no longer
block the growth of axons the second
strategy is to introduce factors that
work directly on the cellular machinery
of the damaged neurons to boost their
capacity to heal themselves for example
researchers are trying to make the
neurons more receptive to pro-growth
signals from their neighbors receptor
molecules called integrins seem to
disappear as neurons mature so
researchers are looking for ways to
smuggle integrins back into damaged
neurons researchers are also
experimenting with adding in the growth
factors themselves for example proteins
igf-1 and osteopontin have again been
shown to spark axon
growth a third strategy has the
potential to combine many aspects of the
first to a study in rats has shown that
mesenchymal stem cells or MSC s
naturally homed in on the site of injury
and protect against secondary damage
caused by the immune system they also
appear to promote apps on regeneration
repair damage to the axons insulating
layer of myelin and may be able to
directly transform into new neurons a
small trial using MS es in humans was
completed last year and the results are
due to be reported soon it's likely that
a successful therapy will involve a
combination of these ideas hopefully
giving patients with spinal cord
injuries a brighter future